so uh welcome Yancy Thanks we we wrote
about Kickstarter last March and if
you'll forgive me I've to go to my cards
here because at the time we led our
story started with an example of a
company that had built a mount for a
camera strap they were asking for
fifteen thousand dollars and they raised
sixty three thousand dollars in six
weeks and we thought that was pretty
incredible sixty three thousand dollars
in six weeks in February tenth I believe
it was a video game company called
double fine raised a million dollars in
a day and as Mark and Chris were
discussing and as you might have read on
the front page of the business section
of the New York Times yesterday a watch
company called pebble has now raised a
seven million dollars in four weeks it's
a great sign of the explosive growth of
the Kickstarter platform it now rivals
the NEA in terms of the amount of arts
projects that it funds and Yancy's here
to talk a little bit about about on its
on its third birthday sort of the state
the state of the Kickstarter platform so
so where's where's Kickstarter at right
now give me some sense of the shape of
the business sure well saturday was was
Kickstarter's third birthday so the site
launched on April twenty-eighth 2009 we
celebrate with a party in bed-stuy was
fun but you know today as of now about
two million people have backed a project
on Kickstarter there have been about
22,000 projects that have been
successfully funded and collectively
there's been over two hundred million
dollars that's moved through the system
and so it's growing a lot you know you
mentioned the Double Fine project there
is a million dollars in a day that was
about ten weeks ago and there there
hadn't been a project raising million
dollars before that day and that day
there were two projects that did it and
there have been six that have done it in
the past ten weeks and so it's
definitely
peaking in some kind of way and it's
also just been there have been some
really great projects that have come
along but yeah it's it's a it's an
exciting time is there anybody out there
you may be too embarrassed raised her
hand who doesn't know how Kickstarter
works okay so we don't have to do that
okay great so what what do you think the
why the explosive growth is it just that
more people are using Kickstarter are
the projects getting better or more
ambitious our people but what's the
what's changing well I think that you
know people are learning the best way to
use it to use the platform and we don't
even know the best way to use it there
was actually very little instructional
copy on the Kickstarter site for the
first two years because we thought this
is a new thing we actually don't know
the right way to do things so how could
we say it's better if people just learn
from each other and I think there's a
nice knowledge base that a lot of people
are drawing from it's been very helpful
I think the other thing that's helped to
just that people you know you don't have
to explain what Kickstarter is as much
anymore I guess is that just showed
before you know maybe thirty percent of
people's videos that have to be
explaining how Kickstarter works and
that's just maybe not as sexy or as
creative as other things people might do
but you know we always thought that for
us you know for kicks her to grow it
would take a long time because it was
kind of a new thing to talk about money
in public in this way to engage with an
audience in exactly this way and that it
might take some time for people to get
used to and so I think that that that's
happening but it's interesting when
there's still some some segments some
creative worlds that are more
comfortable with Kickstarter than others
you know I think that it's it's kind of
strange to talk about money in public
sometimes and say for fine artists or
for like cool rock bands you know
they're not so sure about that and so I
think there's still there's still a lot
a lot farther to go and a lot of the lot
of the mediums out there mm-hmm and can
you give an example of any current
projects that are out there that you're
particularly fond of where they use
Kickstarter in the correct you know well
you know it's funny there II you guys
wrote about him and and a couple issues
ago but but Bob left has had a great a
great little rant about Kickstarter
today we're he's pointing at the pebble
and wanting to musicians for not using
it in the right way i should say Bob
less it's is a
music industry sort of expert and rack
on tour and a blogger who writes these
sort of cranky posts about what why
music the music industry is is terrible
sure and I used to be in the music
industry so I was a rock critic for for
about eight years before before
Kickstarter but he had a really good
piece just about how how bands should
think about Kickstarter how they should
think about it's not about you it's
about doing something for your audience
and I think that's I think that's right
i think that is the right way to think
about it and yesterday a woman named
amanda palmer who used to be on a record
label and got dropped and she's sort of
queen of the internet in some ways and
she launched a project yesterday and
she's raised a quarter million dollars
in the first 24 hours and so we're used
to seeing those kinds of totals only
being for gadgets that's what people
talk about for kicks or with those kinds
of explosive things gadgets but I think
it's you know the growth or the
potential of any project is just
relative to who started it so for for
Amanda Palmer do that much in the first
day is is really awesome and really
exciting and I think it's a reflection
of what she brings the table and also
just the malleability of Kickstarter as
a platform you know if it's quitting
tarantino one to launch a project
tomorrow you could probably raise 25
million dollars right now everyone has
their own their own shadow that they
cast and an audience that they can bring
and it's been interesting to watch you
know Kickstarter's began as a fairly
modest platform for arts projects people
recording their cds or what have you and
before long you start seeing all these
other kinds of projects involved you
mentioned gadgets being a big one design
projects video games and restaurants are
actually sort of pre-funding using
Kickstarter so what how does that change
what you do how does that change the
character of Kickstarter well you know
we really we really stick hard this idea
that Kickstarter is for creative
projects and admittedly creative
projects is a pretty fuzzy phrase it's
it's it's hard to precisely define it it
really does mean things by people things
that spring from the imagination we
really like projects that are someone
pursuing some kind of creative
expression more than some you know
maximization and
and so we do have a bias in that kind of
way I mean the what really drove us to
start Kickstarter I mean Harry Chen
who's our CEO and co-founder he first
had this idea over ten years ago and he
had it when he was living New Orleans
and he wanted to put on a concert and
there's a lot of reasons why it couldn't
happen he thought if only people could
have paid beforehand and then if enough
people paid the show would happen if not
it wouldn't happen this way that sort of
tests test an idea and when we were
really working on early on it we were
driven by was just this notion that the
only ideas in the world that really had
much value that could find support from
traditional forms of funding where ideas
that could make money or things that
were good investments things that were
business ideas but if you had something
that was just creative just something
stuck in your head that you just wanted
to see exist in the real world and that
was really the extent of your ambition
you know you didn't have a lot of
options if you had a rich uncle that
would work if you had you know credit
card he could you know rack up a lot of
dead on that could work but it was it
wasn't easy and so we liked this idea of
creating a space where things could
happen simply because people wanted them
to and there was no greater interest in
that and so I think that that's what
Kickstarter has done and we're
particularly proud of that being done
for the kind of idiosyncratic you know
projects that wouldn't happen anywhere
else I think those the ones that we feel
most romantically about but yeah but it
has extended to do a lot of other things
just because it's a you know it's a
platform it's a platform that people can
do a lot of other things with so that
yeah there are there are a lot of these
design these technology things now but
they still make up a very small minority
of what happens on the site tech related
projects make up about five percent of
the total projects on the site but if
you read the internet it appears they
make up ninety-nine percent of what
happens like Kickstarter I understand
they're exciting and you know an iphone
accessories something a lot of people
connect with because everyone has an
iphone and it's not so true for some
theater production you know and soho but
it's still the theater production in
soho the documentarian going to South
America to make a movie about the Amazon
that is still the vast majority of
what's happening on the site but how
much of the funding you know there
the percent of the projects maybe five
percent but how much the money it's five
percent of the it's ninety-five percent
of the projects and eighty-five percent
of the money so you know definitely
these these design and technology
projects do have a blockbuster potential
that is often seen the pebble going
right now is a good example right and so
that's true but there's still you know
film is film as the largest category in
film is also the place where
Kickstarter's had the most real-world
impact so this year has been exciting
there were 17 kickstarter-funded films
at the Sundance Film Festival there were
33 at South by Southwest there were 12
here at tribeca last week and that's
well over ten percent of the entire
slates of three of the most prestigious
film festivals in the world and can is
coming up in a couple weeks and I think
it will be similar there too and so
there you're seeing a real world impact
of these things that the internet is
making that might seem like they're
novelties or you know less real in some
kind of way they're being honored by you
know the toughest critics the toughest
curators in the world right and so you
know these things are real which is
great but let's go back to that fifteen
percent sure you know when when a
company raises seven million dollars on
Kickstarter based on a five minute video
and a blog post you know what that has
to raise a lot of challenges for
everybody for you for the for the
founders themselves for the funders how
do you kind of police this how do you
know it's easy to imagine a super
villain reading the business section the
New York Times and saying seven million
dollars huh like how am I going to yeah
get some of those well you know we don't
we don't investigate projects we have
this we have a screening system when
things come in and basically you build
your project and then you submit it to
Kickstarter for review and we're
checking it against a set of guidelines
and the guidelines list three things for
things has to be a project meaning has a
beginning and an end it's not open-ended
so I see starting the business something
that's not a project is it retire it
requires maintenance to exist you know
this will produce something that's a
project has to fit one of the categories
in the site there are 13 they're all
kind of in the creative space and it
can't be a charity project and it can't
be a fun my life project and
and and that's it so we screen based on
that when someone says you know I'm
gonna do I'm gonna make a watch I'm
gonna go make a record you know we don't
call up the studio where they're
thinking about making the record to say
or these guys really making the record
you know if something if something is
really doesn't have a lot of information
we'll ask them to add more information
but you know we're not we're not
checking any of these things and what
we're relying on is the fact that you
have the millions of people who are
using the web and these people's
networks that are really vetting the
projects for everyone else because there
is an all-or-nothing funding system if
enough people support a project it
happens and it gets money if not people
don't it doesn't happen and fifty-six
percent of projects don't meet their
goal so that was the ones that the crowd
is saying no we were not interested in
this so there's a police thing that
happens there but really you know we're
relying on the crowd to do that and we
don't want to get more involved in that
because I think then then you just
become another gatekeeper and especially
because a lot of things people are doing
are very ambitious you know we've had
two projects in the past year that would
hugely affect the infrastructure of New
York City one was the plus pool which is
these these designers from Columbia have
designed this porous membrane that you
can drop into a body of water and it
will cleanse the water the moves through
it and their idea is to drop this in the
East River and turn the East River into
a swimming pool it's it's incredible who
wouldn't want that right and so that's
one another one is one that just
finished called the low line which is
from another couple other urban
designers here in the city and there's a
right by the kicks to office the
delancey street station and the lower
east side there's an abandoned terminal
in there you can see it from the jmz
platform and they want to turn it into a
park and they have these fiber optic
cables that will bring sunlight down
below the ground and both of these
projects are incredibly ambitious and if
we are judging these from the
perspective of a bank loan officer or
you know or venture capitalists or
anything like that we're going to say
this is pretty ridiculous but instead
these people are just appealing to to
regular people and they're saying you
know do you like this is this is this
capture imagination
something that you're into and both
projects were funded and and have a nice
head of steam behind them as a result so
we like being that being just that
opportunity for people being a place
that is about creativity and that is
about opportunity and where people can
have their chance yeah I mean you
mentioned that right the whole point is
that not that you're a different kind of
gatekeeper but that you're not a
gatekeeper at all so you have a well but
we are i mean that's that's i mean it's
it's not entirely true we have we have
we have rules right we've set we've
created a space we determine rules for a
space and then we say come and use this
so there are we are gatekeepers in a
sense that you can't raise money for
charity right but but yes we want to be
you know for I think it's for seven or
eight of the 13 categories on
Kickstarter we accept 95 plus percent of
the projects that come in now at the
same time you know Chris in discussing
Kickstarter with Marcus now referred to
Kickstarter's place to pre order
products and I wonder as people come to
associate the site because of the great
work of Wired magazine and others with
with commercial products and as gizmodo
links to these amazing set of headphones
that are up on Kickstarter you know we
talked about this a little bit about the
danger of it being seen as a commercial
transaction as opposed to a funding
mechanism yeah can you talk a little bit
about about that distinction yea i meant
to channel it's a challenging thing
because we have a large swath of
kickstarter is functioning as a
patronage system in a lot of ways a mix
of patronage of commerce it's a lot of
people going on and supporting their
friends or people whose work that they
like and they're saying cool you know go
do your thing good luck and and you know
they'll get a ticket to the show and the
show happens but it's not there's so
there's some self interest but there's
something else there to for these other
kinds of projects they are functioning
more like a store and a storefront and
it is kind of a separate business you
know we kind of have to businesses
within kickstarter right now and those
things are are more challenging in the
sense that you know we're used to
especially the past ten years of the
global supply chain of you order
something on amazon and it magically
shows up on your door in two days and
you know we don't think about how the
things that we own and consume get made
and we just were not as connected with
it and so
thing that you find a lot of Kickstarter
projects is that things take a long time
it's not very easy to manufacture
something prototyping something's very
difficult you know and so there are a
lot of delays and so you know really i
think my concern is is for backers to
understand that they're likely buying
something that doesn't exist yet you
know it's not like the pebble guy has a
warehouse in ohio just stacked with
boxes of pebbles right now he has to
make these things and you know even for
experienced designers that does not go
perfectly and so i think that i think
that there's a part of that that's
really exciting because you get to see
how things get made and you get to learn
and you get a sense of this thing that
i'm going to wear on my wrist has an
author and there's a process to it and
it's not just something that magically
came to exist and i think that belief is
when it's allowed us to you know create
landfill everywhere because we think you
know who cares right you know it's very
simple and so i think that that is good
but but people need to have the right
expectations going in but as you know as
a business yeah we have a sense of what
we think kickstarter is other people
have a different sense of what it is and
I suspect a lot of a lot of platforms a
lot of companies have to go through
things like this hopefully it's meeting
in the middle is where his is where this
Nets out but yeah I mean we've actually
been we've been kind of resistant to
these projects for a while it's taken us
a while you used to them and I don't
know I guess we're just difficult well
this is the last question unfortunately
we do not have time for Q&A but we're
going to go into a break and yancy will
be around so feel free to tackle him and
ask him your question interesting with
these different is it it's um with these
uh so you have it may be a different
vision for kickstarter than some of you
use your users do any sense of where
kickstarter is three years from now so
obviously changed a lot in the last
three years what happens in the next
three years ah i don't know i mean i
think that our ambitions for kickstarter
are what you see you know the what what
drove us and starting this was a desire
to create a place where people could
just do things and they can do things
for the friends with their communities
and that's it you know
and that that happens and that works you
know it's you know Kickstarter is not
your VC it's it's your community and you
know you have to think about it in that
kind of way and so you know I hope that
we can just keep doing that I mean I
there isn't there isn't any grand shift
there isn't any other idea for what
we're doing I think that we feel
fortunate to be able to do something we
really believe in and that is really
working for a lot of people you know I
talk about you know 200 million dollars
or 20,000 plus projects but those are
individuals those are 20,000 ideas that
might not have happened otherwise maybe
they would have in some other way and it
would've been under more onerous terms
and it would have caused a little more
sweat a little more blood than that
would have otherwise but you know those
are those are real things I mean the
Kickstarter growing is just the
aggregate growth of a lot of people and
and it is it is just it is there they
are networks you know every project is
is a is us it's some us of some group of
people deciding together to do something
and I think that's really exciting and
and and that's what we're really
interested in I mean we don't allow
corporations to use Kickstarter really
we don't allow advertising on
Kickstarter we've capped it a place that
is by the audience for the audience and
I think that this future will be very
similar and it's exciting because
there's a lot that just we as
individuals are capable of doing you
know when we band together around ideas
great thanks a lot you answer you
pressure thanks